as we can tell you from Las Vegas
tonight will tell you why we're here in
a minute owning us now with more
reaction to John Kelly's powerful
remarks earlier today and of course all
this breaking news as it relates to
uranium one and the author of the
brand-new book billionaire at the
barricades the populist revolution from
Reagan of Trump and soon-to-be host what
are you gonna start working I don't
understand this you get the show and
you're not on the show yet what's up
with that October 30th
trick or treat finally what are you
dressing as what are you dressing on can
we coordinate our outfits for Halloween
please come on Ken
John Kelly I thought today gave one of
the most powerful yep beat downs to the
left the media and those that hate this
president today yeah he basically said
how dare you as a Goldstar father
someone who served his country in
uniform defending freedom liberty our
sovereignty how dare you politicize all
of this and though it's the way kelly
says it which is also so great Sean it's
from the heart very emotional his love
of country shines through his deep
devotion to America and this is such a
gotcha town that I'm in right now I mean
you're in Vegas I was in Vegas last
night by the way we just passed each
other but this is a gaucho of town
everyone's gotcha I gotcha gotcha
everyone's ratting on everyone else and
I think Kelly comes out and says this is
about America this is about our men and
women in uniform who sacrifice day in
and day out we understand the sacrifices
because this is what we do and all of
you who are wagging your fingers at
Donald Trump just just take a pause take
a breath and understand that you know
the country is bigger than any one
person I thought it I mean I teared up
it was it was amazing so we've got this
uranium one issue now that is blowing
wide open and the media is ignoring it
you got bribery kickbacks extortion
money laundering and what we now know is
they knew in 2009 and they had all of
this evidence in 2009 and they still the
Vladimir Putin who the media has been
talking about for
year clearly wanted to take over
America's uranium marketplace and in
spite of all of that evidence they shut
down the eyewitness they allow us to go
through and yeah and collusion one
collusion I mean if there's ever a case
for collusion it is this
we don't allow a whistleblower basically
he basically is a whistleblower
informant to help Congress do its
Article two oversight duties on all of
this now that's just bizarre and and
Shawn if you ask anyone on the street if
you went out on the street in Vegas
tonight you said okay like China or
Russia wants to buy X and X would allow
them to be much closer to a nuclear
weapon nuclear weaponry advanced nuclear
power or spirit enemy yeah do you think
the United States should allow a 20% of
that to go to Russia and any country
that is not our friend and anyone off
the street I better be 98% of just
people who don't know anything about
this would be like are you kidding me is
that it is that a trick question
so there's a lot more here to be to be
divulged and the shame on the media for
focusing on a fan of the inflation they
hit it and the Trump administration all
right I got to say two things to you
number one Congrats on the success of
your book and teaching your book tour
number two can you please come to work
well I'm gonna be the same Laura
Ingram's next I'm sitting here ready
every night I got the football hands
ready I'm ready for that football